i understand that and i'm not even
saying that there's something
exceptional in that regard about islam
although the rate at which it happened
was quite remarkable but it still it
presents us with a problem doesn't it i
mean everyone it presents everyone with
a problem
and the problem is well for example the
problem is reconciling the idea of
turning the other cheek with the idea of
a just war a defensive war or an
expansive war for that matter and of
course that issue is relevant to islam
because islam exploded
outward and produced the biggest empire
the world had ever seen in in the in the
space of a few short centuries
so that well so then you ask well what's
the spirit what is the spirit that
animated that and is that attributable
to the islamic doctrines themselves
i don't know the answer to that now let
me tell you the answer to that okay
and this is what i want to tell you
conclusively and this will help build
bridges honestly because we can maintain
the warlord thesis we can maintain the
expansionist thesis but here's what i'll
tell you
islam has a has a capability to be
expansive
and it also has a capability of making
peace treaties
and it does and it should do whatever is
in his best interest just like every
country should do whatever's in his best
interest
[Music]
hello everyone um i'm pleased today to
have as my guest discussant muhammad
hijab and
this discussion has been postponed a
number of times because of illness and
i'm very glad that we're able to do it
today and i thank him for his patience
in continuing to pursue this and being
willing to talk to me despite i think
being delayed three times which is
one more time than is unforgivable but
in any case muhammad hijab is an author
a student of comparative religion and a
philosopher of religion he's the
co-founder of sapience institute and is
a researcher and instructor for that
organization he has a ba in politics and
a master's degree in history he's
acquired a second masters in islamic
studies from the school of oriental and
african studies
hijab has also completed a third
master's degree in applied theology from
the university of oxford where he
focused on the philosophy of religion in
applied settings he's now doing his phd
in the philosophy of religion on the
contingency argument for god's existence
and many people i was looking a while
back
for people to talk about islam with and
many people recommended that i talk to
muhammad hijab and so i talked to
mustafa akhil a couple of weeks ago he's
known more i would say on the liberal
front
and so i'm very pleased to be able to
talk to mohammed hijab today thank you
very much for joining me today it's very
good of you
to put up with the delays so no no no no
thank you for having me honestly it was
a pleasure
well so i'm going to ask some some
really basic questions because the the
it's very difficult to understand
another culture from the outside um you
and you also have
for as an outsider you have no idea how
much you don't know about what you don't
know even you're blind to your own
ignorance and so i'm going to start with
basic questions
i don't i wouldn't say that i have a
tangible understanding of islam i mean i
have some understanding of christianity
i've been able to get the sense of
christianity
at a reasonably deep level i would say
at least compared to other things i know
and i've kind of felt the same way about
certain aspects of buddhism and taoism
but
as a religious
system a system of thought islam has
remained relatively opaque to me despite
the fact that i've done a reasonable
amount of historical reading and so
what do you what what is it what is it
in terms of practice and belief that are
absolutely core as far as your concern
to
practicing the islamic faith
well the first thing is i think we
should start with the bare bones basics
and the bare bones basics is first to
say that we believe in god
and the kind of god we believe in is one
god
worthy of worship in fact the quran
makes
a series of arguments
rational arguments for why we believe in
the type of god that we believe in for
example in chapter 52 verse 35 of the
quran it says
where they created from nothing or by
nothing or were they themselves the
creators of themselves did they create
the heavens and the earth
they have no certainty in other words
the quran is hinting here at the fact
that it's impossible for something to
come from nothing and it's it's
impossible also for something to give
rise to itself
and so the universe for example if we
take this as an example couldn't have
come from nothing and it couldn't have
created itself it couldn't be
self-generating and or self-maintaining
and they can't be a world in fact the
quran would indicate there cannot be a
world with only dependent things things
that require
other things in order to exist
ad infinitive and so what is required
outside of the series of dependent
things is something which is independent
which all things depend upon and which
itself depends upon nothing and this is
what the quran refers to as asamat or
the idea of god being self-sufficient
um and independent so the idea of a
prime movement it's a prime mover
argument and you think it's a kind of
prime mover
a lot of
why do you think that why do you think
that the same argument that you put
forward in relationship to the
generation of the universe can't be put
forward as an objection in relationship
to god
you know because you're you you make a
logical case that something can't come
from nothing and something can't create
itself but you move you from a
philosophical perspective this isn't a
religious critique from a philosophical
critique
perspective you just move the problem
back one step what advantages do you
think there are to moving the problem
back one step or am i mischaracterizing
it well i'll tell you what
dr john peterson what you've said is
very similar to what richard dawkins
said in a debate
with uh the archbishop of the then
archbishop of canterbury and he said
that well if you if you have and he said
this debate he made this argument in
oxford and and he said that if you look
at the universe well if you're saying
that god has made uh the universe in
this way then your god who's more
complicated and he would add this layer
of complexity yes uh this your god is
more complicated would require it even
greater he would require even greater
explanation
greater god yeah yeah so really
interestingly anthony kenny who who's um
an agnostic himself he's a philosopher
an agnostic
he came in and he said well actually
take a look at this you've got an
electric razor which is made up of many
different component parts and you have a
cut throat razor which is made up of one
part and he said although the the
electric razor is more complicated it's
it serves less functions than the
cutthroat razor because the cutthroat
razor can cut your throat and it can
also cut an apple for example
and so it's a fallacy to assume that
just because something is complicated or
that something has many features and
attributes that that thing itself
requires an explanation and in fact if
we had an infinite regress of such
explanations and obviously that would
lead to a kind of absurdity so even you
know well-meaning atheists and agnostics
in the field realize
the redundancy and the philosophy and
the argument that is put forward by the
likes of richard dawkins who
who said that kind of thing and i would
also add
to that one point the argument from
composition which is usually a corollary
to the composite to the contingency
argument usually is made in the
following way that everything that is
made of parts
is contingent that the universe or say a
multiverse is made up parts therefore a
universe or the universe and all the
multiverse is contingent
the the parts that we are talking about
neurologically are things that can be
attached and detached so that doesn't
apply to god classical season doesn't
say that god is made of parts the same
way as human beings are or as universes
are or multiverses are and so and in
fact the quran hints at this itself it
says
that the one who created you and
composed you and configured you in any
form that he wished he put you together
and so the fact that you have such
configuration in the universe
indicates that the fact that you have an
external sorting agent
has has particularized the universe in a
certain way and that has composed the
universe in a certain way so the the
argument really is
uh that things which are made of
attachable and detachable parts that
those things are contingent that doesn't
apply to god on any theistic paradigm
now what we would say though sorry to
kind of drag this on a little bit is
that this would disqualify something
like the trinity from being true and in
fact the quran this is the islamic
position
is vehement in its uh opposition towards
a triune god so for example in chapter
23 verse 91 it says
that god hasn't taken a son and he
doesn't have any gods with him if that
had been the case each god would have
taken what he has created and they would
have tried to dominate one another
the idea therefore that there can be
more than one all-powerful entity is an
inconceivable and unintelligible idea
from the islamic paradigm so it's seen
as
problematic to say the least or
conceptually impossible to say even more
to suggest that something like a trinity
can be true when it's talking about for
example
mary and jo mary and jesus it says
something very simple
yet anytime that both of them used to
eat food so in other words the
impossibility of something limited like
jesus
a man being god at the same time being
unlimited because the definition of god
is that he's unlimited is open
do you think that there's a divine spark
in human beings
no but we don't think there's any kind
of divinity at all islam is categorical
about this because the way we define
divinity is extremely strict we say that
the divine attributes of god are
specific only to god
so
what's the characteristic element of the
human relationship with god
so what's the central what's the central
what's the central um you say structure
of value within the human being that
makes them worthy of respect say in the
sight of god or worthy of value in the
sight of god the quran says
we have
we have dignified the child of adam so
that we do believe in something called
human exceptionalism we do believe that
human being has been specialized or
specified among all other things in
creation to be uh to have free will for
example to to have a personal
relationship with god to have a loving
relationship with god people don't
realize this especially from the
christian tradition but one of the names
of god from the islamic tradition is
that he's the loving one al-wadud in
arabic in the quran as well so we
believe that the relationship that human
being should have with god is a loving
relationship but
it's one of submission this is the main
thing islam doesn't mean peace islam
actually means submission islam comes
from the root arabic islam and what it
means is submission and really what the
picture is in the islamic cosmology is
that everything in the universe is
submitting to god
everything the laws of nature have been
placed there by the law maker which is
god and so
we as human beings are volitional we
have free we do believe in free will but
we also believe in a theological
compatibilism
um and so
a kind of uh predetermination is
actually one of our pillars of faith to
believe in that
so in that sense we have to voluntarily
submit to god in the same way that
everything else in creation is what does
what does that submission mean what that
means is that all the prophets and
messengers came before time so this is
the meta narrative of islam abraham came
moses came jesus came and all of them
came with exactly the same message and
that message is to worship to believe in
one god and to worship in only one god
and to do that you have to follow a
guidance so each and every single one of
those messengers they came with we
believe in our narrative they came with
two things effectively they came with a
message which is to worship god meaning
to submit to his laws
and also
with with some kind of evidence space to
suggest that they are prophets so some
of these stories would have been
known obviously to you've done a
biblical series so i know you're very
aware of those stories we have very
similar stories like in moses abraham
jesus but they are slightly different
those stories are slightly different in
fact sometimes radically different
especially considering some new
testament kind of narratives and so
what the the the thread that joins or
the flesh that joins all of these kind
of um
messengers and prophets is that they all
came with one fundamental message which
is to believe one god worship one god we
believe that the prophet
hang on i i'm still not understanding
this exactly okay i'm not sure what you
mean by belief like the way you laid
that out was in some sense propositional
right right you made a you made a
logical argument for the existence of
god but yeah you you you take the
existence of god as as given in some
sense to begin with because of your
faith and then you provide your belief
with a rational um argument but it
wasn't derived from a rational argument
and so i don't so does it when you talk
about belief do you mean belief in a set
of propositions about the nature of god
and and if you do or don't what
what do you believe and how would you
separate out that belief from what you
term as worship
right so actually there's there's one
thing that ought to be known that in
islamic theology we believe in something
called the fitra which is an ina
instinct to believing in god and now i'm
not sure if you're aware of the work so
why bother why bother with the
propositional arguments then
it's don't to me they just seem like a
side a side venture you know
some scholars have said that in islam
sorry yeah okay no no yeah i i in fact
some modern day
philosophers of religion have that kind
of a stance like alvin planting god he
seems quite you know agnostic about the
other thing i mean we can the thing is
what we're saying is it would be
committing something like the
naturalistic fallacy to suggest that
just because something is the case or
there is or fallacy maybe it's just
because something is the case that i
ought to be the case so in order to
prove
the the or it's a demonstrative proof
for those who are in what we call shack
or doubt
and this but the truth is as as you've
mentioned
and as as in the literature like for
example justin barrett
has uh this in his cognitive psychology
psychological or cognitive science
literature i'm not sure if you've come
across
his stuff but basically yeah basically
what he says is that we have an innate
his words exactly receptivity to
believing in god in 2011 the the oxford
anthropological society they've done a
huge study of 32 000 children and what
they found was that children innately
and intuitively instinctively have a
belief of a higher power of some sort
now they are born with that belief
and in fact in one of the papers
in in
justin barrett's book he literally
mentions the fitra or the islamic
theological concept of an instinct in
believing in god what's his last name
barrett
how do you spell that i think double r
double t i believe
justin barrett okay that's useful yeah
well it just strikes me that in you see
the problem with debating
people like richard dawkins about the
existence of god is that
he will
formulate the argument in propositional
terms
and then force the person so to speak
i don't imply any melis on his part but
as soon as you accept that the
the battle is to be won on propositional
grounds you've already accepted a
certain definition of god and i think
you lose the argument instantly i think
the the argument
for instinct something like that
is is much more powerful because one of
the things i'm led to to wonder when you
laid out your argument is
well what what purpose does belief in
god serve or your faith in god let's say
and i think belief see it's also really
interesting to try to distinguish
between belief in something and faith in
something like if you have imagine you
have faith in the good
and so how do you demonstrate that well
you believe that good is more powerful
than evil
you believe that you should act in a
manner that's that's
that's uh appropriate to the good and so
then you act that way and that's the
faith
the faith is demonstrated in the actions
yes but it's not exactly prop it's not
exactly propositional and you know
partly because i would say if you look
at good and evil for example
it's not that easy to make the case that
good is more dominant or more powerful
than evil all things considered in human
affairs now i think it is but you know
what i mean you can't make a compelling
propositional case that that's
absolutely true
but you can reflect your faith in your
actions the thing is you mentioned
richard dawkins i wrote as part of the
sapiens institute we wrote a small
booklet called the scientific delusions
of the new atheists
and we we refuted him on the on this
kind of thing if you read the god
delusion he literally spends five pages
of hundreds
talking about uh the cosmological
argument and i think two talking about
the teleological argument or the
fine-tuning um i do think that uh not
much work has been done by new atheists
in
new atheists meaning like you know the
four horsemen or whatever in trying to
actually tackle these arguments and
sometimes when they're on debates with
other philosophers of religion i don't
think they from my perspective at least
they don't actually provide a
satisfactory defense yeah well the
instinct argument is an interesting one
because yeah it seems to me that part of
the
and this is why i was pressing you
pressing you to some degree on the issue
of the definition of worship is that i
don't see much difference between the
instinct to worship and the instinct to
imitate and i do believe that there's
compelling evidence psychological and
biological yeah that we human beings
have a remarkably strong instinct to
imitate
and the question is well what is it that
we're oriented to imitate and i think
we're or like if you look at the
developmental psychology literature for
example
it seems quite it seems to be the case
that if a child has an intact nervous
system and they have one or two good
models around them that they'll be drawn
towards those good models and imitate
them and and develop quite healthily
even under rather stressful
circumstances
and you know that instinct to imitate
also underlies
phenomenon phenomena like the experience
of awe
and and the experience of charisma
and that charisma you know has an effect
on attentional function and on the
proclivity to behave and so
i think the propositionalized arguments
deliver the religious
ideas over to the propositional camp and
that's dominated already by scientists
in many ways it's it's a losing battle i
don't think it's the right one so
worship you you you just so okay so one
thing the west and islam agree on
although i think islam is part of the
west by the way because we're all people
of the book
i mean the triune god in the christian
sense is still subordinate to a higher
order unity and so
and so there is a powerful movement
towards monotheism in judaism and
christianity in islam and that seems to
be a point of some agreement we're also
all three societies are also people
who've made a decision collectively in
some mysterious manner that a book
should sit at the basis of culture
a specific book that's been aggregated
in in a strange way in a mysterious way
and so we also agree on that
and so that's you know that's a starting
place at least and obviously there's
been a lot of interpenetration of ideas
between islam and judaism and
christianity i mean the prophets in in
islam are the same prophets that go
through the three major western
monotheistic religions yes and so that's
a fair bit of commonality yes and so
that that's a good place to start
building bridges and so so okay so islam
is stringently monotheistic
and then the submission idea what
exactly i mean god is ineffable in in in
a sense and
so
what does submission mean exactly right
and how is that related to worship and
how is that related to the good let's
say
on a practical level right so i think
what you said before there was a point
you made about the finding faith through
action and i think that we would
strongly agree with that and that's
that's what we believe
our definition of faith
is what you what you basically believe
in the heart say on the tongue and do
with your with your actions that's
that's like a definition of faith faith
for us or iman the idea of iman
in terms of in terms of the good now
there are different conceptions in islam
of the good uh but the main thing is we
believe that god is good quite similar
to what christians believe and therefore
he wants good for human beings um and
that the injunctions of god are also
good in terms of submission
and this is extremely important here
submission can only be done
through revelation that that is our
position the position is that submission
is actually impossible without a
guidance and the guidance we believe
obviously is the quran
but we also acknowledge the we also
acknowledge the torah the original torah
that was sent to moser moses and the
original injil or the gospel that was
sent to
jesus but what we have is we can call it
a doctrine of taharif which means
corruption so what we believe is that
what happens is with these books you've
had
basically corruption happen to them so
we don't know what is uh what is part of
that book and what is not part of that
book we don't know exactly what jesus
said and what isn't because there is no
clear chain of narration back to jesus
christ
um but going back to the point of
submission
submission is to follow the prophets all
of them because a muslim cannot be a
muslim unless they believe in revere
love and respect
all of the prophets including jesus
moses abraham and all of them
follow all of them and in their way and
once again we believe that they were
divinely inspired so and there is
evidence that all of these prophets come
with and i i think i was on that point i
was telling you that um
the the differentiating factor between
the prophet muhammad and the rest of the
prophets is we believe whereas all of
the other prophets came for their people
in their time we believe that muhammad
came for all people and all times
that's certainly what christians say
about christ
yes but in the bible you'll find
up you know some verses that are saying
i've only been sent for the lost sheep
of israel
and so yeah there's some tension you
know you see this you see something like
the rise of a universalism a spirit of
universalism that surpasses fundamental
tribalism even of a religious sort
but and it seems there seems to be a
struggle that takes place in the gospel
in some sense conceptually between this
reversion to something that's more
tribal and something that's genuinely
universal but i think the universalist
spirit wins out quite clearly in other
words christianity wouldn't be an
evangelizing religion it's designed to
try to bring everybody because
attention sorry it's largely because of
the tension between paul and james
and a lot of well modern-day
christianity is based on poor line kind
of interpretations rather than kind of
james was very much a man of the law
himself he was
you know he didn't believe that the law
was abrogated he didn't believe that in
fact there's huge tension obviously in
in the bible between both those two men
and obviously there's historical reasons
for that as well but but what we will
say is
we would say that there are clear verses
in the bible like for example we point
to isaiah 42 11
where that indicates a new prophet
that's going to come and in fact isaiah
42 11 in particular is extremely
important because it even specifies the
region
it says it will be sent to the people of
kedar and the people of kedar as in
genesis
kedar was the son of ishmael
and basically from him is the lineage of
muhammad or the arabs if you like
and so it is a whole discussion in the
whole of isaiah 42 about a new prophet
going to come and he is going to come to
the people of kedar and the people will
be rejoicing on the mountaintops and in
fact the name of a mountain in medina
which is present-day saudi arabia is
mentioned which is the mount of salah
and and so we would say that actually
muhammad was a continuation of jesus
christ and that jesus christ as a
prophet uh also in the bible doesn't say
that there's not going to be another
prophet after me and so that there's no
reasonable reason for us to think at all
i think christ actually said that the
believers
would be able to do the things he did
and more
so there's actually a prophecy of of a
multitude of prophets in some sense
which would perhaps be a consequence of
taking the fundamental doctrine the
spiritual doctrine of christianity
seriously
yes i mean as we said interpretation in
many ways we are all followers of christ
and that's another point of commonality
like
we
we see the messiah jesus christ as a man
who had done wonders and miracles and
signs as the bible states we believe
that he was immaculately conceived we
believe that he cured the blind he
raised the dead with god's permission we
believe all like most of the things that
you'll find
we actually believe in those things
there's huge commonalities between islam
and christianity from that perspective
the the major difference is we would say
that it's not intelligible or
conceivable or pardonable to believe any
human being with a date of birth could
ever be called god
and and this is where where we kind of
diverge from the christian mainstream
yeah so so okay so let me let me tell
you about some things i've been thinking
about in relationship to that
well
you know that
nietzsche announced the death of god in
the late 1800s and
you know what the consequences of that
being have been at least to some degree
and of course dostoevsky was talking
about exactly the same things at pretty
much exactly the same time but
the
philosopher of religion
eliad
in his historical investigations
indicated that
the the death of god is something that
has happened to many cultures in many
places over many times it's not a unique
event in let's say western history
and his explanation for that at least in
part was that
as there's a movement towards
unification under a monotheistic
umbrella let's say which is perhaps a
precondition for the union of diverse
people
the
the one of the consequences of that is
that that central unifying
value becomes so abstracted because it
has to cover such a multiplicity it
becomes so abstracted that it becomes
sufficiently it it flies away in some he
called that deus abscondis if i remember
correctly is that the idea of the spirit
just flies away because it no longer has
an attachment to the world
and one of the ways that christianity
solved that if you think about it from a
psychological perspective was by
was by insisting upon the presence of
god
in a canonic form right in an emptied
form in a partially emptied form in the
person of christ in a particular place
at a particular time and it's it's a
variant of the prophetic idea although
taken to its absolute extreme the
prophetic idea is that there are people
who are marked out in history marked out
by god by their relationship with what's
highest in some spectacular manner
and so i guess one of the things i would
say about
the the islamic islamic resistance to
the idea of the divinity of christ is
that there is an emphasis on islam on
the special status of prophets of
certain prophets and their particular
special relationship with god which
seems to elevate them
above other men in some important sense
and so and drawing a line precisely
between that claim and the claim of
divinity incarnate is not an easy matter
so well i i would actually disagree with
that i think there's a clear distinction
in the quran between
the the prophets and ordinary men and
this is actually one of the clearest
distinctions i i because but is there a
clear distinction between the prophets
and some spark of divinity inside those
men
yes so what do we define as a spark of
divinity
well i would say it's what it's partly
what gives people charisma although it's
not always that it's also partly what
marked these men out as being prophets
i mean it's what we look at when we say
that man is great that's a great man
that's a great person that was a great
deed well yes yes fair enough but i
would say also embodied virtue and it's
embodied virtue that is in some sense
reflective of the action of the highest
value operating at a local scale yeah so
that's exactly what we believe we
believe in we believe in the doctrine of
infallibility
and so we believe that all prophets
basically did the best thing possible
for human beings
and and this is narrated about the
prophet muhammad in fact
and you have impeccable virtue basically
the highest level virtue and this is
something about all the prophets and
obviously if that wasn't the case we
wouldn't they wouldn't be sufficient
guides for us in terms of humanity so if
that's what you mean by a spark of
divinity i don't think there's a point
of resistance yeah well these things are
hard to sort out right the terminology
and that's part of the complexity of
these sorts of discussions
yeah for us
divinity is basically having the
attributes of god so once again since we
know god through his attributes
um from that perspective
that human beings cannot possess the
fullness of the attributes of god if you
want i can respond that seems like a
perfectly reasonable perspective i mean
you know we're all limited infallible
creatures and and and we'd be a foo we'd
be fools not to see that the the
attributes of god
how are they knowable is that only
through relationship with the with the
book or is that is that also does that
also have an experiential element as far
as you're concerned so
what i can do in fact is i can recite
for you a couple of verses from the
quran because what we believe is
they have they are known through the
revelation and i can recite for you
maybe 10 20 second verses and translate
for you and show you what i think it
will give you more of a flavor of what
you believe
sure okay do what you will so the quran
states in the end of chapter 59
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
so let me read the translation from from
because i want to get this wrong right
these two verses i think are probably
the two best verses that answer your
question in the quran
allah is he i'm going to get something
maybe
a bit better
uh translation all right
here's allah
that there is no god worthy of worship
except for him the king the holy the one
free from all defects the giver of
security the watcher over his creatures
the mighty the compeller the supreme
glory be to him
glory be to god high is he above all
that they associate as partners with him
he is allah the creator the inventor of
all things the bestower of forms to him
belong the best names all that is in the
heavens and the earth glorify him and he
is the almighty the all-wise so these
are i would say the two
potentially the two best verses that
summarize
for us so right so it's an attempt to
use a multiplicity of virtues to decide
to define a supreme source of good so
okay i have a technical question for you
a procedural question i guess
um
when we're talking so you sang those
verses and then so here's what happened
i asked you that question you sang those
verses or chanted them it's or
combination
okay but there's a there's a melodic
element to that and i don't understand
the language
and then you translated them and so why
approach the answer to to my question in
that manner
because we believe that the quran in its
original language
has an element in it or has a has a
virtue if you like to it or an attribute
to it which cannot be felt or
experienced
phenomenologically if you like
through um just mere translation
we believe so yeah and so what what
purpose does that serve in the
discussion with someone like me
what it would do hopefully because we
believe the quran has divine qualities
itself
the quran itself has divine qualities so
we believe number one it's a cure
we believe there's a physic it's
actually a physical cure as well as a
spiritual cure
we believe that it's a guidance
we believe that
uh it's it's something which will
literally put you in a psychological
state of ease
so in a sense what it will do it
hopefully you know will
have an effect on you which is
physiological maybe psychological
and in a sense it's like giving you
something to taste rather than just
explaining what it tastes like you know
and um so that's why
i feel how do you know when that's how
do you know when that's appropriate and
when it's not
it's i mean you obviously don't all that
well but you don't yeah i don't mean
that
no but so that's why i asked the
question it's obviously you're making
distinctions you're not you're not doing
what you just did with what it is
i want to give you the full islamic
experience you see yeah okay okay you
know what i mean
yeah okay part of it is to part of it is
to let you hear what the quran sounds
like
um
so you can kind of if you hear it maybe
you go somewhere to a muslim country and
you hear that in the background or you
may be even walking down i don't know
you're from alberto is it
yes yes amazing you know that
yeah i think you've mentioned it before
i've been to i've been to edmonton
actually in canada there's there's a
muslim community there maybe you'll hear
it in someone driving and oh i remember
that i know what that is you know
so it's just okay to gain maybe why did
that make you smile
i because
because that would make me happy i mean
quite quite openly and honestly because
we want the best
i mean to be honest with you if you want
to be totally honest yeah now that's
what i'm hoping for yeah all right
why you asking before we start the show
i mean one of our not objectives but one
of our hopes
okay is that people embrace islam and
become muslims
that's islam is an evangelizing religion
it's a religion which aims literally to
enter every home there's a there is
actually a prophetic saying that says
that islam will enter every home not
necessarily meaning everyone become
muslim but it will enter every home in
some way shape or form you mean like
what's happening right now with this
podcast
there you have it you see
it's part of it no there's a there's a
series of predictions that the prophet
makes and this is part of the evidence
package we believe
okay so you also talked about the fact
you know when we started just before we
started this that part of the reason
that you're talking with me is that you
hope to build bridges so this gets down
to some and i want to return to the
fundamental attributes of islamic belief
i don't i don't want to let that part of
the conversation lag but you know
christianity is also an evangelizing
religion and yes christians hope the
same thing yes so well you know what
what that has caused
and is still causing
and so you know we have to contend with
this all of us that are alive now and
so we have two evangelizing religions
they're both they're both fundamentally
monotheistic they they emerge from a
tradition that's quite similar there's
many things that they have in common but
the border between them has been rife
with with conflict for
a very long time and that has not ended
and it's become more distributed and so
forth but
and one of the things about
islam i would say that frightens the
west
is that
especially in the modern world is that
it appears that it's difficult for
religions that aren't islam in islamic
countries to manage to maintain
themselves to any degree whatsoever
and now look i understand
i have said that
with a certain understanding also in
mind
when i look at this from a psychological
or an anthropological perspective i also
see that
as human societies have come together
and organized themselves in ever
increasing sized groups
that the necessity for an emergent
monotheism as a uniting factor might be
crucial and it's clearly the case that
the emergence of islam united diverse
people
and in that union there is a kind of
peace that's that's the definition of
union and how much strife and force and
conflict and catastrophe had to attend
that
unification is a matter of debate we
don't know how these things can be
managed we don't know how to manage them
any better but we're still stuck with
this problem now we have two fundamental
monotheisms that are head to head now i
know that's that's an oversimplification
and hypothetically we're both motivated
by the desire for something
approximating peace yeah and so and we
want to build bridges and that's why you
and i are talking yes but but i don't
know what to do with the mutual
evangelical uh what would you say
impulse like my sense is
christians turn to yourself
you're a problem you can fix yourself
you do that and the other things are
going to sort themselves out of their
own accord
and i do believe that and i actually
believe that that message is in some
sense centrally christian it's like look
to yourself
and be the example
and that's the best way of let's say
convincing other people if that's what
you're interested in it's also the only
real effective way of bringing peace
so well i'm not sure look i'm a
traditionalist muslim okay which means
i'm orthodox i'm not a liberal at all
in fact i oppose liberalism to be quite
honest with you in in the sense i
criticize it i don't think it's the
truth with the capital t
uh
i don't so a lot of enlightenment ideas
i oppose them openly right
and so i'm speaking from the perspective
of someone who is a traditionalist
muslim someone by that i mean i stick to
the quran and the sunnah which is the
prophetic sayings and the jewish
prudential tradition
which is derived from those two sources
and other sources as well but this is a
tradition traditionalist perspective
which i think represents the majority
here's what i will say the first order
of business jordan peterson uh dr jordan
beason is for us i think to acknowledge
that both
religions
have
a capability of peace
okay this is extremely important
and that requires education so i'm just
gonna be honest with you like for
example the warlord comment that you
made okay i've about the prophet i think
that is part of the problem i have to be
honest because yeah i want to get to
that dr jordan where
his here's the thing
i don't see you as some kind of enemy of
islam i genuinely don't i think i see
that
and i don't want to be either i have
lots of people in the islamic world who
are listening to what i'm doing and and
watching and being supportive of it this
is poverty and here's what i'll say to
you now i can tell you that as a matter
of fact like my close friends and
traditionalist muslims listen to you i
mean that's for sure
um in fact they love it you think they'd
have something better to do no no no no
because a lot of your views kind of
coalesce with the islamic viewpoints
especially on like the nuclear family on
alcohol i know you've done your phd on
alcohol actually your thesis and um
obviously islam is one of the only
religions in the world that bans alcohol
completely and uh drugs and stuff but
going back to the point like
we we said we want to build bridges and
we said we want to understand each other
and i think what you said there's
important we do have two evangelizing
religions
but we have to look at the character and
the life story of the prophet because
with the prophet muhammad
here's two things that we we have to
look at number one there was the meccan
period and i'm sure you're aware in that
period
uh the prophet muhammad was you know
first of all he was an orphan
um and then he got married to a woman at
the age of 25 her name was khadija she
was actually his boss and then after
that you know
he said that he received revelation at
the age of 40
in the in the mountain
in the cave sorry and then after that
uh there was a time of persecution and
then after that
um
he went he went to different places he
went to tariff
which is a place outside of mecca he
went to el hazrat who are two clans two
tribes
and what it was is that he was he was
trying to get support for his project or
the monotheistic project because he was
being boycotted et cetera he eventually
got it from hazraj these two tribes
because they actually believed in the
religion of islam this is documented
like without a shadow of a doubt this is
what happened and then is this in the
medina is this the medina period that
you're speaking out so this is actually
technically the meccan period
okay still the meccan period yeah so
right before medina literally was
established because medina is the it was
it was so called after the prophet
because medina just literally means the
city in arabic it was called the ether
before and then they changed it into
madina to nabi like the city of the
prophet and so that's why it was kind of
called medina after that
in that time period so you've got 13
years of medina
the vast majority i'm not going to say
at all but the vast majority of wars
that took place
in fact all of the wars that took place
before the conquest of mecca were
defensive so the pagan arabs went to
medina and tried to siege it
and all of these are names of wars and
in fact there was according to one
scholar there were 19 such wars
in 10 years so that's almost an average
of two wars every year and for me i see
that actually as an evidence for prophet
because the prophet was actually
fighting in these wars he wasn't just
you know throwing people around telling
him to fight for him he was fighting in
them and there were defensive wars
um
so in that time period what happened was
i'll give you a question okay so okay so
let me let me interject something there
because that's
that's that's very that's a very hard
thing for me to
to get straight in my mind yes now
um
i would say that and the division in
islam that occurred almost immediately
upon muhammad's death and which has not
been rectified to this day quite the
contrary that's also you know that's a
problem for everyone it's a problem for
muslims it's a problem for christians
it's a problem for everyone and it's a
problem that could really get out of
hand now it's not like i don't know that
the protestants and the catholics were
at each other's throats for you know
hundreds of years so
but that's that's not the issue at the
moment so
now in in islam there's a tremendous
emphasis on christ's doctrines as well
and there isn't any evidence that christ
himself took part in let's say wars
it's hard
let me okay what do you mean okay well
if you if you analyze christ as an
archetype when he comes back in his
second coming he is going to dominate
the world
and one can say well that's not the
historical christ but when we're when
we're looking at him in the way
look that's a reasonable that's a
reasonable objection
and i
has a understand
has that martial element and i don't
think it's reasonable to use the
archetypal representation as an argument
against the historical reality and look
i'm not saying to you
that i know that what muhammad did was
wrong that isn't what i'm saying i'm
saying that i don't understand
how
participation in those defense of wars
let's say but then that was also
followed by a tremendous explosion of
islamic expansion right the biggest
empire the world had ever seen in a very
short period of time right at right at
europe's doors
and so
and that was also followed by the
severance of the islamic faith into two
major categories and and internecine
conflict there and so there's that that
stream of of
of armed conflict activity i i think
that you're
with respect i i don't think you're
getting the history fully right here
because well
go yep that's fine cool
the the the war in jamal and safin that
the wars between shia and sunnah or what
would then be it's not really between
sunnah because quite frankly shiism had
not been established does it but the the
wars of the companions how many people
died in those wars
do we have any numbers
for maximum we can say but it's but it's
fair look fair enough man and it's not
like it's not chris it's not like
christianity hasn't been rife with
internet scene conflict yes
but the fact is is that it was almost
immediately after muhammad's death that
this fracturing took place among the
people that were closely allied with him
and it was a bloody fracturing and it
isn't obvious that it's been written
how how bloody was it well how bloody
does it have to be you know it doesn't
take much okay
well let's be honest let's be fair yeah
yeah
let's be fair right with with with with
the wars that took place 30 to 40 years
and it wasn't immediately after because
you said that in the video the day he
died that's wrong he didn't happen the
day he died it happened that it's four
years after
it happened thirty to four years after
and how long how how many people how
many members of muhammad's immediate
family survived during that 30 years
my understanding was that most of his
immediate family died in armed conflict
relatives family died in his own
lifetime
yes well i'm not speaking of them but
i'm speaking of what happened after he
does that's right because yeah okay look
first first fact
muhammad
sallallahu
um
all of his children died in his life
okay except for one
so most of the members of his immediate
family and his wife died khadijah died
his uncle abu talib died his other uncle
hamza died they all died within his
lifetime either due to illness
or due to
some other some other cause war for
example like one of the defensive was
hamza died
and by the way muhammad forgave his
killer and that's something which which
goes against the warlord thesis because
when he then conquered mecca
when he conquered mecca he was actually
no fighting i'm not sure if you know
this it's called fat
when he went into and conquered mecca he
didn't fight anybody it was no fighting
there were a few people that that were
exempted but he actually quoted what
joseph quoted to his brothers in the
quran in the quran which is letter three
by alec
that no blame is on you today and so and
this by the way is a bedrock example of
forgiveness in islam because these were
people that were persecuting him for 13
years these are people that were that
killed his uncle like i said there's one
person called washi
who um who literally killed his uncle
and
and mutilated his body and he said to
ashi i forgive you but i can't i can't
see your face because of how
how
he said
he said can you keep your face away from
me because i can't psychologically i
can't believe my faith but i do forgive
you he said so he forgave people that
killed his own family members
and this was after he he himself
attempted a treaty with the pagans
called hodei
and so they broke the treaty and that's
what initiated the conquest of mecca
which was
not a conquest that was uh fighting now
if you compare this because i think the
comparison if there's any comparison
that can be or should be made
it's the it's jesus's second coming with
muhammad in the medinan period not in
the meccan period in the meccan period
both were being persecuted jesus in his
life and muhammad in his in the meccan
period but jesus when he comes back he
will then get authority
and he will be i uh he will be ruling
with the iron scepter according to the
bible he will be crushing his uh
he will be crushing his enemies uh as it
says in corinthians under his humbling
his enemies under his foot uh and
killing and violent stuff so in fact
the the i i will actually argue today
that the new testament representation of
jesus christ in his second coming is way
more violent than muhammad's conquests
in uh the medina okay well look like i
said i wasn't i wasn't trying to make
the case i wasn't trying to make the
case that
what happened in mecca or medina was
wrong like so let me explain that a
little bit
so christian europe fought a defensive
war against the nazis
it isn't obvious that that was wrong i
don't think that was i wouldn't say
that's defensive
well okay fine but but i understand the
concept of defense of war
america
america when america got involved in
world war ii
it was not under immediate threat by
germany and they colonized it and here's
the thing it caught it it overtook
western germany you see
here's the thing the term warlord that
you use with the prophet you've never
used with harry truman you've never used
with uh
with uh roosevelt you've never used with
winston churchill all of which conquered
countries literally in wars because i
feel like there is there is a bias there
and you actually never used it with
anybody else aside from the prophet
muhammad in your public output and i
think that's unjustifiable i think that
you have biblical prophets like moses
you have biblical prophets like um
joshua you have you have the jesus in
his second coming all of which were
warrior prophets
and and and and you've only used the
term uh uh warlord with the prophet
muhammad i think that is unjustifiable i
think if we what what is it that caught
what makes someone a warlord in you
then if if it's conquering lands then
harry truman is a warlord
then uh
you know
and so on and so forth in fact
i guess that's a real that's a real
tough question isn't it what makes a
warlord and what makes it just war it's
not like any of us have the precise
answers to that i think that's what
partly what we're trying to hash out the
definitions of the word warlords the
definition of the word lord according to
collins is that someone who acquires
force by aggressivity and violence
you push back on me so i'll push back on
you to some degree okay well it's
certainly the case that the expansion of
the islamic empire was
accomplished by a tremendous amount of
war-like activity and that wasn't
defensive
now look i understand that monotheism is
a difficult state to attain
and that monotheistic societies have
emerged in the midst of conflict
throughout human society i understand
that and i'm not even saying that
there's something exceptional in that
regard about islam although the rate at
which it happened was quite remarkable
but it still it presents us with a
problem doesn't it
i mean everyone it presents everyone
with a problem
and the problem is well for example the
problem is reconciling the idea of
turning the other cheek with the idea of
a just war a defense of war or an
expansive war for that matter and of
course that issue is relevant to islam
because islam exploded outward and
produced the biggest empire the world
had ever seen in in the in the space of
a few short centuries
so that well so then you ask well what's
the spirit what is the spirit that
animated that and is that attributable
to the islamic doctrines themselves i
don't know the answer to that now let me
tell you the answer to that okay
and this is what i want to tell you
conclusively and this will help build
bridges honestly because we can maintain
the warlords thesis we can maintain the
expansionist thesis but here's what i'll
tell you
islam has a has a capability to be
expansive
and it also has a capability of making
peace treaties
and it does and it should do whatever is
in its best interest just like every
country should do whatever's in its best
interest in the pre-modern world we did
not i think this is highly anachronistic
in the pre-modern world there was no
such thing as un it was a realist
international relations framework
whereby everybody was fighting everyone
the roman empire didn't care
about what you it didn't care about you
quite frankly it was expanding itself
the persian empire was expanding itself
and the and the arabian peninsula was in
between both
and so it could have either been
swallowed by those two other empires or
could decide to in fact we will impose
our government on on them before they
impose it on us and it decided the
former rather than the latter it decided
to expand and in fact the prophet in his
weakest of times he predicted that that
would happen you know there was one more
in particular where they were they were
starving and it's called khandak and he
hit iraq and he said
the roman empire has been conquered he
hit another iraq again he said forte had
fairest that the persian empire has been
conquered and then he knocked the rock
again he said he said this in his
weakest moment he said that the yemen
has been conquered i see that the
expansion of the islamic empire is a
proof of islam and you know it's not
just me even historians say this how
bonaby rogerson he said the fact that
islam spread
to the roman empire and the persian
empire is equivalent to
the the is equivalent to eskimos taking
over russia and america i believe it's
miraculous if anything that this
happened i don't think it's
unjustifiable i think actually during
peace and then why didn't you stop it
why did it stop at europe's borders so
to speak
if it wasn't
because of uh
it wasn't successful there it wasn't it
stopped where it it
couldn't go further but the point is is
that it's not like the christians at
that time in rome cared i mean they did
the same thing for years they were
expanding themselves well that's why i
said that's why i said i wasn't making a
private fantasy case that this was wrong
i'm trying to understand it and so and
you objected to my
use of the term warlord and perhaps
rightly so you know perhaps that was an
injudicious comment i was rather shocked
when i was reading islamic history when
i
encountered the degree of violence that
surrounded these events and so you know
maybe i was like
appreciate what you've said there i
think this that shows real sincerity and
and it's it's one step closer to
creating real
uh meaningful relationships between uh
well i think and i think you're you know
your defense that well the world was a
battleground of empires and you know if
it's if it's push out from our territory
or be encroached upon and dominated then
it isn't obvious that being encroached
upon and dominated is the right
approach the correct approach the most
moral approach let's say
um especially because there'd be no
shortage of bloodshed that would also
accompany that
so sometimes you're in a bad place and
but you know it's not an easy thing for
any of us to what would you say mediate
between doctrines like turn the other
cheek and love your enemy and also at
the same time discuss the necessity of
both defensive and sometimes expansive
expansionist wars right we all have to
contend with that and and and and it's
very difficult to contend with it the
arguments are extremely complicated
you're absolutely right and i think
what's really important here because i
think this is a huge misconception is to
to outline because i know you're against
totalitarianism you're very uh you know
vocal about that and i want to tell you
that we are also a point of commonality
we are also against totalitarianism
if we if we define totalitarianism
as
a central government trying to encroach
every private and public matter
of the citizens lives and this is
something we don't believe in in fact
this is very important islam does not
say you have to force people either to
become muslim or that they can or they
have to live in islamic lifestyle
within islamic governance and i'm not
sure if you know this but at the time of
the prophet he made a constitution okay
with jewish people with other people who
are not muslim at the time protecting
their rights protecting their rights to
worship whoever they wanted to worship
and actually even guaranteeing that if
there were intruder forces that they
would be protected like that as well
is that the is that the arrangement made
with like fellow people of the book
essentially yes it was the arrangement
i'm aware of that
yes and so not only this but this was
implemented at the time of the caliph so
um
and so on this is we believe in a kind
of pluralism in a sense and in fact this
is i would argue that it was more
legally efficacious than what we have in
the west do you know why because
permission you think that is true now
yes even let me tell you why because
christians were given courts
that they could rule in and that the law
would be efficient it would be a
parallel dissenting law system which
would have effect
so they were so they would effectively
be able to go and judge their affairs
outside of the the general framework of
islam
and in fact this is in the quran
and and they took this even though we
believe that the torah has been
corrupted to some extent
uh the the remnants of they can use the
torah whatever corrupted version they
have to rule their affairs and this is
something that was was was done at the
time of the prophet
timothy
and so even now we would say and i'm not
saying that the whole of islamic history
has presented this convavencia that we
saw in spain between muslims christians
and jews a good time and
or other times
yeah i'm not saying that of course i'm
not but what i'm saying is that i think
it is disingenuous to to to appoint
islam as if it's been the most
intolerant of all of these religions
look at the alhambra look at the spanish
inquisition look at the crusades look
look at the colonialism that has
happened in the name if not even not in
the name of religion there's no
disputing with me the fact that in some
sense we all have the blood of history
on our hands yes i'm firmly aware of
that
and
it's an existential burden for everyone
and i'm not i'm not trying to make the
case that this is particularly or
uniquely true of islam i certainly know
that that's not the case what i'm saying
instead is that these are things that we
have to contend with and we don't
exactly know how
we still have the problem of these two
evangelizing religions right that
they're going head-to-head in some sense
yes it's true evangelizing doesn't mean
that it's compelling and and this is
very clear well okay okay now that
that's now there's an interesting point
no it's not that the points you made
before aren't you know because i kind of
think well let he who can tell the best
story win
and then that story also has the best
actors so to speak right and so i would
say the proper mode to conversion is
something like shining example
and then if you're governed by a
doctrine that is in fact divine and
you're managing to
embody that in the sense that gives you
the glow the charismatic glow of
embodied divinity
two steps removed let's say and people
are willing to abide by your words as a
consequence well more power to you and
that's a lot more efficient and
effective than compulsory war armed
conflict or any of those things and i
mean this is a constant problem and i
would also say that given our
technological mastery now we really
can't afford this anymore we have to
solve this problem of defense of war
expansive war evangelical religion you
know how to go about you not how to go
about uniting us under some umbrella
that isn't so vague that it means
nothing how to preserve our traditions
from the past and i can't see any better
way than each of us trying to be shining
exemplars of our tradition
and then letting that goodness shine
forth in a way that people you may you
may it may be the case that we'll find
that the better we are the more we like
each other i mean wouldn't that be a
kind of union under something
approximating god that all good men
could see in each other a reflection of
something that was the highest
and that that should be compelling in
and of itself absolutely but i think
in terms of the jurisprudence in terms
of what islam is capable of people in
the west
must realize that islam is fully capable
of peace this is what must be realized
how do we how do we know that it's not
despite the quran and the sunnah or the
sayings of the prophet and the actions
but it's because of them
if you if you look at the quran and you
look at for example chapter 4 verse 90
or if you look at for example
chapter one verse ninety chapter two
verse one ninety one ninety you'll see
that the the um
the islamic commandments are clearly
sometimes about defensiveness but
sometimes also clearly about um
about creating peace treaties and this
treaty of hadibia is a bedrock example
we are
so long as there's peace treaties there
is peace and so in terms of muslim
countries they can perpetually create
peace treaties with other people muslim
people
uh
even more so because we believe we're
fully under contract
and
and therefore you're willing to abide by
a contract
this is the thing let me tell you
something peace okay the thing one of
the clearest for me and i've done a lot
of work studying liberalism studying
christianity and studying islam okay
this the clearest
commonality between liberal theory and
islam
is contractarianism and contracts
consent that is a serious thing because
in in liberal theory you have the theory
of consent and in islam you have the
same thing contracts are binding the
quran says
even with people outside the faith yes
especially with people outside the faith
why especially why especially is that
part of the tradition of hospitality in
some sense because if if you break a
contract with a non-muslim then you're
driving them away from islam
okay so yes that's definitely true with
that absolutely so remember islam is
islam is attempts
to attract people to its own religion
one of the categories of zakat was
money that you pay to non-muslims so
that they can feel comfortable and they
can feel as if you're doing them a favor
and there's relationships going on
it's a category it is a category of
zakat which is one of the five pillars
of islam to to give such money so the
fact that islam states
in chapter 5 verse 1
oh
you believe fulfill your contracts that
is generic
if you don't stick to your words then
this shows a lack of character it shows
that you in fact one of the signs
one of the signs of a hypocrite
is that he goes against a religious
hypocrite is that he either
if he if he makes a contract he goes
against it it seems one of the most
despicable things do you think that
there are other
things that i've said about islam that
we could talk about right now that i
could
clear up and
you know because i don't want elephants
under the car but i don't like elephants
under the carpet or snakes under the
carpet so are there other things that
i've said that you that that people on
the islamic side who would maybe like to
not be my enemy
let's say
um because who needs enemies after all
unless you want them
um are there other things that you think
places that i've misstepped in a serious
manner that should be rectified as far
as your concern in a serious matter i
will confine it to the warlord comment
because i think that's the one that most
muslims well you know people in the west
are afraid of islamic expansionism and
they're okay so let's let's go after
that again so the other thing that i
find upsetting let's say is the civil
war
in islam
yeah well yeah so if it didn't tell
people to fight each other
i mean
fair enough
islam doesn't say that islam doesn't say
this should be a civil war it's in fact
it was predicted but it was never
encouraged in fact the quran clearly
encourages against civil war yeah and i
would say the same thing about
christianity
by the way protestant and catholic wars
sorry
just to interact it gives yes a remedy
in fact the quran is the only religious
book i know that tells you how to deal
with the civil war
well
it says that if and if one of the groups
rebels against the other group then
fight the one that is rebellious until
it wakes up to the command of god
so
islam is categorically against civil war
islam is islam is clearly for pluralism
it's not for compulsion these misnomers
and misconceptions must okay so okay so
fair fair enough and as i said i know
that the protestants and the catholics
were at each other's throats for years
and despite the fact that of there being
no justification for that let's say or
quite the contrary in the gospels so
this isn't a problem that's unique to
islam but it is an ongoing problem in
islam and it's not like there isn't
sectarian strife in the west i also
understand that and so that that makes
people watching the the religious
community say wary because well for
obvious reasons and so why do you i know
you can't answer this question in
totality but islam hasn't been able to
bring its own house into unified order
and so
why why do you think that is and how is
that related to islam itself if it is at
all there's nothing exceptional about
islam in that regard and this once again
is
you made this point many times i'll tell
you something again
just because there's multiple
interpretations of something it doesn't
mean that that thing is false like there
may be multiple interpretations of the
killing of jfk it doesn't mean that jfk
didn't get killed
people differ on things
which
especially if there's a lot of those
people which there can be more than one
interpretation about now in terms of
body count there was actually a
book that was written um
and with there was a chapter of the book
by i think his name is nazir
and he he done a study looking at the
numbers of people that have been killed
in all the major world religions and he
puts christianity firmly at the top i
mean this doesn't require too much
historical research anyway look at the
30-year war compare that with any wolf
look everywhere islam okay okay so so
the point you're making the point you're
making is twofold is
it's not
the necessity for civil war isn't
embedded in the doctrine and there's no
reason to throw stones at the muslim
world when we could perfectly well look
to our own history
and i do think what we should do is look
to our own history i really believe that
and i believe that we all carry
historical guilt for the bloodshed
that's preceded the structure of all of
our societies
but we in the west we look at the muslim
world and we see that it's it's it's
riven apart
and we wonder well
i i know i know there's a hypocritical
element to that i'm not claiming that
there isn't it's not like we have our
own house in order but you have to
remember something else you have to
remember there was a colonial reality
that existed
where
britain france and many of the european
countries and
the western european extensions they
dominated the muslim world for the last
2 300 years
and so yeah but i think i don't think
that's a particularly good argument no
it's very good
well hang on hang on a sec i'm not i
don't want it i don't want to knock it
away completely
the rift that i'm talking about though
was was evident far before that now the
fact of that colonial complication that
that could well be the fact of that
colonial complication could could well
be a contributor i know the the nation
state lines first of all were imposed
they were imposed quickly they were
imposed arbitrarily and without
and partly partly that was a consequence
of what would you say having to do a lot
of things very quickly in the aftermath
of a terrible war i'm not trying to
excuse it but it was complicated and i
know that that's left the middle east in
this you know uh
uh a group of nation states that now
comprise the world in a very complicated
situation so it's a reasonable point but
the rift was there before
and so okay
here's what i'll say to that yeah it's
you you're right to say that there was
arbitrary lines that were drawn but it's
not just that there were arbitrary lines
that were drawn you mentioned the middle
east syria for example which is where
most of the problems are happening now
in terms of the middle eastern countries
it's probably number one maybe maybe
libya number two but say syria for
example they put three four five ten
different factions all of which have
differing understandings
of of of religion of ideology of
whatever it may be together that
produced wars
you know you had christians in lebanon
fighting sunnis shias fighting sunnis
and this happened especially after the
revolution a lot of it so
imposition of a false unity that's
really what happened yeah if you look at
how what they're doing now like look at
leblanc as an example you you have to
have a christian president and a sunni
prime minister and a shiite i don't know
what it is first minister or something i
mean they have systems that try and
mitigate these issues but it's a mess
because you're putting people that have
different visions
of how to run a country together and
they have their similar demographics
it's like 30 40
20 and so that creates more wars but
they put them together almost on i would
argue on purpose to be honest just
divide and conquer
if you look at countries like denmark
and sweden and norway which are very
peaceful and very prosperous they're
also very homogeneous and so and they're
relatively small so the problem of
governance over diversity is much
reduced in countries like that it's
simpler for them to be at peace because
the culture is relatively homogeneous
and so i take your point it's not easy
to bring
a true diversity into something
approximating a unity especially when
that unity has been
in some sense arbitrarily oppo imposed
and also rapidly and arbitrarily imposed
so that's a reasonable point yeah um
well i think what it is and i've seen
this in your reading list it's like when
you when you follow kind of
bernard lewis's
uh or samuel huntington's kind of clash
of civilization narratives sometimes you
miss the nuances and these are the
nuances yeah well that's for sure
they're myriad contributory factors to
why and it's i still don't see
how islamic countries this like almost
50 muslim majority countries
are in
like in general like you made a point
about economic uh potential one time you
said yeah yeah i wanted to ask you about
that because well that's another thing
that's quite a mystery is that
the
comparatively speaking per capita the
muslim countries are not that productive
economically
there's four muslim majorities in one
sense
there's four muslim there are four out
of ten muslim majority countries in the
gdp per capita top ten brunei
kuwait and saudi arabia oh yeah well i'm
not sure that i'm willing to grant the
fact that most of that wealth is
generated by oil as a co as a no that's
kind of productivity the point stands is
you said per capita gdp
sorry yes fair enough and you were right
to call me on that that isn't what that
isn't what i meant i'm sorry because i
don't think i'd well no i do i we got to
get the words right here we got to get
them exactly right because these things
matter
um i don't they
well all you know that oil wealth is
often a curse as well as a blessing
so outside of oil wealth yeah brunei
brunei is another country that's in the
top 10.
okay so let's talk about brunei what
have they done right in your estimation
i don't know much about brunei but i
know they're in the top 10. i have to be
honest with you you know but yeah well
that's part of this low resolution
knowledge that we all have a problem
with right i mean it's
talking about these things is very
difficult because you have to know
everything to do it right it's not that
easy to know everything i know that they
were trying to implement sharia to a
very high level and
whatever they're doing is it's not
because it's not despite the sharia and
but what i also know is that the
methodology is flawed when you look at
muslim majority countries and say well
they're not doing well as uh non-muslim
director because
the ottoman empire 400 years ago was
doing better than most countries yes yes
yes yes absolutely
and i know i know and historical time
frame matters you know because it's
definitely so that's a perfectly valid
point let me tell you something john
peterson uh you are an epistemological
pragmatist from my understanding you
said before in an interview that
anything which serves life is is true
that's what you said
i think with sam harris
if this is the case and you said it's
nested in darwinism if this is your
position
then the truth of the world it's nested
complicate it's nested in a very complex
manner in darwin yeah but if it's i mean
i think that highest truth is something
like love and i think it's very much
associated with the notions of love that
are essential to religious traditions
and so i'm with you but you still
believe that truth is utility and you
still believe because that's the
pragmatist position and so truth is
relative
what i'm saying yeah but i also believe
that the basis of utility is love
that's the way i'm not so sure that i'm
not so sure that you and i differ so
much on that particular
piece and i want to say to you is this
right
first of all pragmatically islam is
doing the best because if you're talking
about evolution then we're talking about
reproduction and survivability and islam
has got the highest birth rates in the
world today it's the fastest growing
religion by a mile by by 2100 it will be
number one so in your definition it
should be the most true by the way
number one number two is this
is that well that's a lot of love all
that reproduction
[Laughter]
they'll try and change the subject now
look so number number number two is this
look at dr john peterson as i'll tell
you that i think i've seen your struggle
against post-modernism i've seen your
struggle against nihilism and i don't
think you will be successful and i'm
sorry to say like this and the reason
why i don't think you'll be successful
is because your framework is it's
self-relativistic if it's utility and
epistemologically pragmatic then truth
is relative and if truth is relative
what you're going to say to a you you
actually agree with the postmodernist in
that sense you i think you're closer to
post-modernist than you think in fact
the pragmatist position is not
interesting
it's not inconsistent jordan peterson
with
the pragmatic position that you hold
what we are offering you and i'm going
to detail out that in in much more
detail when i go to cambridge and oxford
so okay i don't know you should come i
want you come to one of the talks i'll
i'll
do you want me to get do you want an
invitation oh absolutely get an
invitation well let there you come
because i'm going to tell you one of the
things in islam is to always accept
invitations as well and gifts and i'm
going to send you some gifts as well my
friend yeah all right we need to get you
some gifts
all right so look i'm going to ask you
one more i've got to stop because i'm
getting burned out i i want to ask you
one more question okay and and we i
would like to talk to you again and i do
hope you come in and and join me in
cambridge or at oxford for one of these
talks that would be real good yeah i'll
get i'll get the person organizing the
the the the trip to to extend you an
invitation and so thank you now you
described yourself as a traditionalist
as opposed to a liberal muslim yes and
and we were talking a little bit about
mustafa acual and so why for you is that
traditionalism particularly important
and why why should that carry more
weight than let's say attempts to
hypothetically liberalize islam
what is it doing for you look
we have and this goes back to the
pragmatism point and the post-modernism
point islam
gives you moral anchorage
in and of itself
we believe islam itself has an inbuilt
flexibility but objectively it's an from
a correspondence theory perspective it's
an outside truth which is which is hard
which is strong
and which can oppose and destroy
post-modernism and nihilism and and
that's what i think a lot of your
followers so you think that a
traditionalist grounding is is a more
it's a firmer foundation as far as
you're concerned when a liberal decides
that they want to fuse islamic ideas
with
islamic ideas with liberal ideas they're
assumed they're almost
um they're almost okay fair enough i can
understand that and it's partly why i
have some sympathy for conservative for
the concern
so they're they're admitting that
there's it's almost an admission that is
islam is not complete and it's not
perfect we believe islam is complete and
it's perfect and it's guidance and we
believe we have evidence for that
whether it's the prophets yeah well okay
there's two there's two problems i have
with that i would say i mean look and i
i'm taking your point seriously and i
understand the utility of firm
foundations as a bulwark against chaos
okay yes of course so but but here's
here's two problems i have with that
it's not easy to protect yourself if
you're a traditionalist against the
temptation towards an authoritarian
interpretation and flawed as we all are
you know when we approach let's say
sacred texts we also have to remember
that
it's us who are reading them and divine
though they may be that doesn't mean
we're perfect in our rece receipt of
their message and so it's hard what the
the danger on the on the more
traditionalist side is the slide into
authoritarian authoritarian certainty as
opposed to the slide into chaos on the
more liberal side so how do you how do
you how do you personally defend
yourself against
that well first of all um
authoritarianism on pragmatism and
pragmatism are not
inconsistent because an authoritarian
leader i'm not saying i have the answer
to that problem okay
that's the first thing number two is i
would say you know you've said one time
i think in the lecture that that one of
the miracles of christianity is uh
render on to caesar verse you know
render onto caesar what belongs to
caesar run down to god what belongs to
god what if caesar is hitler
then you've got authoritarianism all
over again so i i think yes
yeah so
you didn't answer my question though it
was a technical question it's a
technical question look and maybe i'm
wrong in the formulation and you can
tell me if you think i am
what i see as a danger on the liberal
side
is the possibility of a descent into
something like chaos that's hopelessness
and despair but what i see on the more
traditionalist side let's say the
conservative side is a retreat into a a
kind of authoritarian certainty and
that's those are twin temptations that
might be what would you say specific to
given temperaments and i was asking you
personally like you're you're a
traditionalist believer
how do you protect yourself you know
your soul
against the temptations of overweight
certainty all right i got you i got you
okay yeah okay yeah no no i don't in
terms of certainty
i i strive for it in fact we we want it
we don't we don't want to we the the
problem is not how do you rectify error
like you know you're not perfect
obviously no no
me personally of course i'm not perfect
but we believe we follow a perfect
guidance
right but you follow it imperfectly
yes and there's the rub right so so
that's my point is that given that you
have to follow it imperfectly given that
you're imperfect how do you defend
yourself against inappropriate certainty
because look if you're imperfect it
means you think you're right about
things you're not right about that's the
definition of compounded ignorance right
yes yeah yeah so
there are things that i you know in
terms of my own personal you're talking
about my own personal face
okay i've got you there are certain
things which i'll agree i will believe
in 100
and there are certain things i will
suspend judgment on
so the things which for me constitute
the anchor i believe the moment i take
the anchor away i plunge into chaos and
anarchy and depression
and that's not something i'm willing to
do for myself
so the the certainty i have is that
there's one god worthy of worship
that god's wisdom and guidance is the
truth
that whatever god says is true that the
prophets are true that heaven is true
that hell is true all that stuff the
things i will suspend judgment on is how
to deal with situations because that i
do believe by the way in a kind of
sharia consequentialism and i do believe
that within the islamic framework is
something called
which is basically the principles of
jurisprudence
that that rules are not always going to
work in all cases
we do believe that by the way so so for
example i'm not allowed to drink alcohol
but in certain cases if it's the last
thing
that one can do with if they're not
going to die if they're going to die if
they don't do it then we can do it
and this is just one like extreme
example we're not allowed alcohol in
islam obviously uh this is one of the
conjunctions
but there are things we do believe in a
consequence an inbuilt flexibility with
that we have to communicate we have to
discuss we have to speak to muslims and
non-muslims alike yeah so
okay okay so still so i'm still not
getting out what i want i want to hear
from you specifically
you know that well all of us struggle
with the desire to have what we believe
be right at all costs right because it's
it well it is satisfying and
and it's difficult to be wrong because
it means you have to improve you have to
look at your errors i'm asking you
personally like when you're dealing with
your wife when you're dealing with your
kids you know how do you know when
how is it that you can protect yourself
against being over weaning
now this is a good question you're going
to get me in trouble with this kind of
thing right now you know these and i
this is a good question what it is is
that you know i've been married for like
nine years now you know
and i've had to learn that the hard way
you know i've had to learn that the hard
way that i protect myself by realizing
or know my own vulnerability my own
fallibility my own weakness the fact
that i don't get everything right
um
the fact that there's another
perspective that there's something
outside of myself which is greater than
me
yeah well that's okay so that's that's
something like you know because
a serious discussion can be had about
the relationship between humility and
love right yes i mean i think a certain
degree of humility is a precondition for
love because otherwise you can't take
the perspective of the other person
like how can you if you exactly if you
don't think you're wrong and i like i
for me and and it's certainly been the
case this was useful in my clinical
practice and certainly in my marriages
i'm trying to be as attentive as i can
to when i'm wrong
and that seems to be a reasonable yeah
that comes out and i think that's really
good that's a good part of your person i
think that's why a lot of people
actually love your work and love you as
a person because you come across as
extremely authentic and sincere that
we don't find that kind of thing in kind
of
it's not like it's it's not like it's
obvious to me that the christians have
it right and the jews and the muslims
have it wrong
and so that's certainly not the case at
an individual level
it's way more complicated than that way
more and so we're just not going to go
for answers if we go for answers like
that we're going to be at each other's
throats and how about we aren't
how about we're not
how about we make peace
hey and so you and i we had a peaceful
conversation so good for us and hooray
and hopefully we'll have some more and i
would be very much like to see you in in
cambridge or oxford and you can listen
to my arguments in a more detailed
manner that way and that might address
some of the philosophical concerns that
you were raising yeah so
so i'll get an invitation out to you
well likely today
so and hopefully we'll be able to talk
again and thank you very much for
agreeing to speak with me i appreciate
it and for correcting me on my missed
apprehensions thank you dr jordan and
you're most welcome to come and speak on
my podcast as well and
as i said a lot of traditionalist
muslims really look up to you and i
think we've actually come quite a long
way in being able to build bridges to
summarize really from my side
so long as today we have realized that
okay islam is a religion not too
dissimilar
okay from the other previous
dispensations as we would we would see
it and that there are things there's a
flesh that joins these religions and
also that
peace is possible
peace is possible well then let's let's
see if we can be good enough people to
actually want peace
let's try and see what we can do all
right man we'll see you i hope we see
each other in the uk and and i'd like to
say hello to all the listeners and
watchers of this from the islamic
community and like
let's see what we can do together man
yeah and you're invited to anything any
mosque i think in the uk will have you
because you've already got the presence
there
just name the mosque and i'll i'll get
you an invitation
send me a send me a suggestion uh when i
send you this invitation send me a
suggestion i don't know if i can do it
on this visit but i'm coming back in i
think march and i'd certainly i'm
certainly willing to do it that's not
only willing eager and i mean that i
mean eager i would love to be welcomed
in that manner that would be a
tremendous privilege as far as i'm
concerned
so
now i think you will be surprised as to
the amount of acceptability that you
have in particular the muslim community
well hooray for that so let's try not to
mock it up with foolish words
all right man good talking to you thanks
again thanks so much
[Music]
you